michael je vous laisse passer le micro à
mélanie et on va parler des différentes
opérations étaient en sable parce
qu'elles se multiplient paris avait un
peu lancé la mode ya quelques années
maintenant c'est partout dans les
yvelines
oui on peut aller à la plage en ville
dans les yvelines aussi on peut
connaître la sensation des grains de
sable entre les doigts de pied alors
pour cela il faut monter un peu plus au
nord du département ont paradis à
verneuil sur seine à la base de loisirs
du val de seine
c'est une grande zone de baignade qui
est ouverte au public tous les jours du
1er juillet au 1er septembre et la
baignade est surveillée de 10h à 19h il
ya donc de quoi être rassuré il y a un
droit d'entrée pour le public à peu près
3 0 90 point un enfant de moins de 14
ans et gratuit pour les moins de 4 ans
et 5 euros 50 pour un adulte alors sur
cette île de loisirs on peut faire plein
de choses on peut jouer au mini golf
pêche à la carpe faire du pédalo et
plein d'autres activités qu'on trouve
sur le site sur saint quentin en
yvelines également et oui là cette fois
à montigny le bretonneux
comme chaque année le parking du gymnase
alain colas se transforme en plage pour
faire des châteaux du toboggan c'est la
13ème édition cette année d'été en salle
écouté les participants on a trouvé que
c'était une très bonne idée de passer du
temps à l'été en sable et tous les ans
et la fidl
le fait que ce soit voilà aussi bien
organisé c'est vrai qu'à pas mal
d'activités je regardais justement le
petit le petit programme donc c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment enfin c'est plaisant
voilà d'avoir autant d'activités le
sable parce que j'adore la mer donc
c'est un avant goût des vacances et
ensuite l'ambiance est plein
d'animations donc amusant c'est agréable
des fois après tu fais la queue sur nuit
on m'a appris des voix y avait un jeu où
elle ou as tu été dans un grand toboggan
après la turquie après la télé c'est
dans une piscine c'est éclaboussait
c'était trop bien
subtilité cette année pour montigny le
bretonneux l'opération est uniquement
réservé aux habitants de la commune mais
c'est un choix de la commune peuvent
s'est liée à la fréquentation des années
précédentes l'an dernier wilfried y
avait 33 mille visiteurs s'étaient donné
rendez vous tout l'été alors cette année
les aînés montants peuvent en profiter
jusqu'au 18 août
et pour ceux qui voudraient piquer une
tête en restant à 50 ans devine pourquoi
ne pas les attrape
depuis le 8 juillet c'est la dixième
édition de trappes l'âge un rendez-vous
qui l'an dernier avait accueilli 27
mille visiteurs au programme de cette
nouvelle édition le bassin de la piscine
jacquemond qu un solarium et de très
nombreuses animations comme des ateliers
du cross
fi des concours de pétanque l'accès est
gratuit pour les trappistes pour les
non-résidents l'entrée est à 7 euros
dispose adultes et 4 euros 40 pour les
enfants mais le billet donne accès au
site durant une semaine et vous
n'oubliez pas les uns les autres que
vous avez des défis à réaliser je vous
vois tous bien sage est ce que vous avez
tous pris connaissance de vos petites
cartes aussi ça vous semble faisable
ce faisable c'est faisable c'est
faisable oui marylène qui va arbitrer
tout ça
grégory compliqué mais pas impossible on
va y arriver aurélie relèvera été très
compliqué tard est-ce que moi faire un
sans faute
michael wei a pas de souci là dessus si
ce sera relevé de souci ça après le défi
n'est pas forcément réalisable
uniquement sur le plateau c'est louis
basty c'est mieux que les gens le voient
quand même oui mais va falloir sortir le
du plateau un moment donné en tout cas
pour ma part d'accord ce serait bien non
on n'en dit pas plus laissé le suspense
la note de nicolas lhenry manon c'est
faisable
oui oui peut-être bientôt relever
bientôt relever la spéciale et mélanie
donc on est on y retourne à 7 cette
chronique dédiée aux différentes
opérations étaient en sable cette fois
ci à plaisir est là c'est carrément
château en sable oui c'est la vie de
château à plaisir si on peut le tenter
pendant un mois et demi le parc du
château se transforme en parc
d'activités c'est la deuxième édition et
des jeux gonflables pour les enfants des
jeux d'eau du beach volley les vendredi
et samedi des animations éphémère il ya
des voiturettes électriques des murs
d'escaladé
c'est des moments à vivre dans les zones
fun et sport mais il ya aussi une zone
zen pour ceux qui voudraient bouquiner
ou tout simplement profiter du soleil
l'année dernière on a fait les pleins
certaines journées à 600 enfants
accueillis avec les familles donc c'est
énorme donc cette année on a bien su
réitérer mais il n'était pas question de
faire un one shot
il fallait absolument que ça perdure
puisque c'est une raie à temps ce qui
fait que maintenant au niveau de l'été
on a toute une série d'activités entre
la nuit la nuit des étoiles mais aussi
la nuit des cinémas et puis ces
estivales les estivales ont débuté le 15
juillet le rendez-vous court jusqu'au 29
août aux moules frites dans tout ce que
j'ai donné ce que il ya un petit rendez
vous qui vous intéressent
le programme est trop vaste j'ai fait
oublier qu'à moitié les choses que vous
avez annoncé
je vais voir cette émission en replay